tannis terre ce sera la plus forte
récession connue en france et dans le
monde occidental depuis 1945
nous projetons qu'au cours de l'année
2020 la croissance sera négative de
l'ordre de -8% qu'on a souvent
l'occasion de se demander qu'est ce que
ça veut dire une croissance de 1% ou 1
et demi pour cent ou 2 % parfois et on
se réjouit quand la croissance est
importante moins 8% de croissance en
2020 ça veut dire que la richesse
nationale va se contracter qu'elle va
diminuer de l'ordre de près de 10% cette
quelque chose de jamais vu qui va avoir
un impact considérable
les quelques chiffres que vous voyez sur
l'écran sont éloquents au total c'est
près de -36% d'activité économique
pendant la période de confinement une
diminution de l'activité dans
l'industrie de l'ordre de 43%
une diminution de l'activité dans le
domaine de la construction dont on
connaît l'importance pour la vie
économique nationale de l'ordre de 88 %
et une quasi cessation générales
d'activité dans la restauration dans les
cafés dans les hôtels pour la plus
grande majorité d'entre eux ce choc
économique
il est propre à la france mais en
réalité il est propre à tous les pays
qui sont confrontées à l'épidémie
céderait en italie c'est vrai en espagne
c'est vrai le royaume uni c'est vrai aux
états unis et c'est vrai dans un très
grand nombre de pays qui alors même que
l'épidémie ne les frappe pas directement
ou avec moins d'intensité voit néanmoins
l'impact de la fin d'activité ou de la
cessation d'activité dans d'autres pays
se diffuser vers eux n'ayant plus de
marché ils ne peuvent plus produire et
là aussi les affaires s'arrête